翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん
これは何だと思いますか？
これは とある島の
自生しているヤシの実だけを使って
手作りされている
バージンココナッツオイルです
私はこれを輸入し
日本で販売しています
実はこのココナッツオイルが
「ダイナマイト漁」という悲劇を撲滅し
とある島の海の生態系を
護ってくれています
今日は私の半生と その中で挑戦した
とあるプロジェクトについて
お話しさせてください
このココナッツオイルの生産地は
インドネシアの地図にも載らない島
カポポサン島です
インドネシアの首都ジャカルタから
1,400km離れたところにある
小さなこの島は
モンスーンの影響で
漁に出られる日が限られており
漁以外の産業も十分ではありません
島民達は生活のために
手っ取り早く魚を獲ろうと
「ダイナマイト漁」を始めてしまいます
海にダイナマイトを投げ込み
爆発させて
気絶した魚を回収します
一度に多くの魚を獲ることはできますが
珊瑚礁は木っ端微塵
魚の住処を奪ってしまいます
ダイナマイト漁は
国際的な環境問題となっていて
漁師達が悪者のように扱われがちですが
実はカポポサン島のように
目の前の生活のために
止むを得ずしなければならないのであって
決して怠慢や無知からくるものではない
たとえそうだとしても
少しの現金収入があれば
解決できるものだと私は思いました
カポポサン島の場合
彼らの生活には欠かせない身近な存在 —
ココナッツオイルが
意外にも その解決策でした
私がこのココナッツオイルに出会ったのは
インドネシアに住んでいる時でした
仕事によるストレスで
アトピー体質の乾燥肌に悩まされていました
見兼ねた友人が「肌にいいらしいよ」と
このココナッツオイルを
ペットボトルに入れて持ってきてくれました
私はその豊かな香りと肌馴染みの良さに
一目惚れしてしまいました
「これ売れるんじゃないの？」と
冗談で言った私に
友人はその島の経済状況が
どれだけ大変かを話してくれました
私は 島の生活のため
そして このオイルの素晴らしさを
日本のみなさんに知ってもらうため
事業の立ち上げを決意しました
しかしこの時 この決意が何をもたらすのか
私は全く予期していませんでした
ただ 島のために何かしたい —
安定した現金収入があればそのうち
ダイナマイト漁も止めてくれるだろう
ただそれだけでした
日本に帰ってからは
奮闘の毎日でした
毎月100kg買うことを約束し
安定した現金収入により 島の生活の
自立と安定を最優先にしていました
私の仕事は瓶詰め
かわいくラベル貼りをして商品化
とにかく必死でオイルの品質を訴え続け
島の現状を訴え続け
みなさんに買っていただきました
目がまわるような忙しさで
オイルを売り続けて半年
大量の在庫を抱えたまま
次のオーダーをしないといけない時期になり
パートナーに弱音を吐こうと
連絡を取った時のことです
「今月来月の輸入量を
半分にできひんかなぁ」と言うと
パートナーは報告してくれました
今はもう誰もダイナマイト漁を
していないこと
ココナッツオイルの売り上げで
ロブスターを半養殖するゲージを買ったこと
「こっちは調子いいから
愛も少し休んだらいいよ」
そしてパートナーは続けました
「それに『ローカルビジネスで
ダイナマイト漁を撲滅した』という
噂を聞きつけて
今度水産大臣が視察に来るらしいんだ
インドネシアを変えるきっかけに
なるかもしれないね」
私は目が点になりました
たった半年でダイナマイト漁が
なくなってしまったんです
その上 海を傷つけない方法での漁に
自分達で移行していました
私の小さな挑戦は
私が気がつかないうちに
島の運命を大きく変えていました
「ココナッツオイルプロジェクトを立ち上げて
ダイナマイト漁を撲滅した！」と言うと
壮大な話に聞こえるかもしれません
ですが私は 私ができる目の前のことを
していただけなんです
「え 楽しそう！」
「ええやん できそう！」
「できたやん やったー！」
という感じです
だからもし 壮大な結果を求めて
挫折しそうになっても
まずは自分がやれることを
やればいいのだと気づきました
与えている影響で
周りが変化しているかもしれないし
目の前で起こした小さな結果が
延いては社会を変えるような
大きな結果につながることがあるんです
実は私は小さい頃から
スーパーヒーローになりたかったんです
この世界には悪い奴がいて
そいつをやっつければ
世界は平和になるんだと信じていました
そんな私は 誰かのためになり
この世の中を良くするきっかけになるような
仕事ができないかと模索していました
例えば22歳の時
神戸でフェアトレード商品を扱う―
小さな雑貨屋さんをオープンしました
私自身がアジアで旅をして
直接買い付けるということで
値段がクリアであると
フェアトレードポリシーを謳っていました
ですが現実は
その原材料がどこからやってきたのか
どのような流通で街までやってきたのかも
私は把握していませんでした
外国人はフェアトレードや
オーガニックと書いていれば喜んで買う
そんな話をお客さんから聞いた時
私もそのうちの一人だと感じました
ショックを受けたと同時に
原材料から生産
流通から販売まで
全て把握している商品を作りたい！
とも思いました
そして東日本大震災が起こりました
私は店を休業し 支援物資を掻き集め
東北に向かいました
私は人の役に立てているという
満足感で満たされ 幸せでした
ですが ボランティアを終えて
神戸に戻ると
店を閉じ続けていたので収入が激減
一気に生活が成り立たなくなりました
ここで 持続的なシステムを
持たない社会貢献は
自己満足の範囲を超えないことを学びました
こうやって私は自分が正しいと
思ってきたことに対して
失敗ばかりしていました
ですが失敗をする度に
何が本当に正しいのか
何が本当に相手のためになるのかを
考える機会に変えることができました
その失敗と反省が
このココナッツオイルプロジェクトには
詰まっています
この 小さなココナッツオイルが
ダイナマイト漁を撲滅する
という結果をもたらしたように
あなたが今 必死に取り組んでいることが
今 成果は出ていなくても
どこで誰を救うか
どんな影響を及ぼすかは
誰にもわかりません
だから自分を信じて
前に進むあなたを
私は応援しています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）